okay so I think that's time hello my
name is Michael Newton you can see up
there I'm kind of ma V double n
absolutely everywhere on the internet
that I exist there's a story behind that
but I'm not going to tell it now because
that's not why you're here and why
you're here is to break your code
because that's fun basically so I'm here
to talk about something called property
based testing it's not a new concept
it's been around for quite a long time
it's not even a new thing in net it's
been around for pretty long time in
dotnet but because it kind of has its
background in sort of Haskell and Erlang
and some of the functional programming
languages it's not something that's
really kind of broken into the
mainstream dotnet consciousness so I
wanted to kind of give you a run-through
of what it is and how it works and how
you can use it yourself for your own
code and the basic idea is is very
simple with property based testing
rather than picking examples that are
true as you would in normal unit tests
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to identify properties about your
code which are tree so kind of the the
archetypal example of this which
everyone uses in their getting started
guide and even the dotnet library which
I'm going to show you uses this example
in their getting started guide is if you
want to build a reversing or a sorting
algorithm then properties based testing
is really easy because other people have
already written reversing and sorting
algorithms and you kind of have this
property you know about it which is you
know something along the lines of I
still want to sort things correctly I
just want to do it faster for my
scenario so what you can do a property
based testing is you can say I want my
new sorting method to always produce the
same result as this old slow sorting
method and the property based testing
framework that you're using will then
try and kind of find examples where that
isn't true so for example you might find
out that your sorting algorithm is not
stable as an if
have multiple copies of the same thing
in your list or things with the same key
in your list it might not keep them in
same order and you know things like that
and the even simpler example is if you
reverse a list and then you reversed
again you have what's called an
invariant property you have a property
which is should be always true for any
input and property based testing
frameworks are great with that because
you can say if I reverse my list and I
reverse it again I should get a list
which has the same items in the same
order as the list that I started with
and so you can write a nice little
property which says I always want this
to be true and off you go now this is
great and if you're like me the first
time you come across this you go that's
a really powerful concept except the I'm
pausing badly defined data from a
mainframe at the moment and I don't have
any invariant properties is this
actually any use to me and the other
thing you kind of start hitting quite
quickly is that what in strongly typed
languages like sort of the.net languages
what the property based testing
frameworks tend to try and do is they'll
take the method that you're giving it
and they'll have a look at the type
signature and they have a look at the
input parameters and they will try and
generate inputs for those functions
based on the types of the input
parameters which is great and all except
that we don't have such a strong type
system that our functions will always
accept any valid value of the types that
we've said so if you are say parsing
something there is probably a subset of
the type string which are actually valid
things to parse whereas all of the other
strings you're not really expecting to
do anything meaningful with you know you
might throw well you might give an error
message for you might might do something
else so it's a bit hard initially to
kind of get an idea of where to go with
these so I've kind of taken two
different approaches and I was
originally give a quite different talk
that I've given before and I've decided
to swap things around a bit so I will
give a link at the end to a talk I did I
think three years ago now where I go off
and I have
look at a whole load of different
examples of kind of real business cases
where I've used property based testing
to test things that you tend to think of
a more sort of day-to-day business code
rather than things like sorting lists or
maths algorithms or things like that
whereas today I just wanted to take one
example and go into a bit more depth
about how we can sort of build things up
from really simple properties that you
can just drop into your code even if you
know very little about property based
testing and kind of eliminate whole
classes of unit tests so you don't have
to bother writing them and also looking
at some of the complexities when you
actually start wanting to test bits of
business logic where you're wanting it
to sort of generate inputs for you but
you also don't want to duplicate the
logic from the thing you're testing in
your tests so that can get quite
interesting and sorts of like that's not
big enough is it
and let's try that we might need to
adjust with the thing slowly is that
fairly fairly readable to people so the
example I'm going to start with is a
little templating library you've
probably seen things like this before
where you can have a string with some
curly braces with a name inside and you
can provide a dictionary that gives
values to swap into those tags so that
you can you know do templates for your
HTML or those kind of things so this is
the example we're going to be working
with throughout and this is similar to
it's not exactly the same thing I've
done in real life this is similar to
some property based testing code I've
written in real life in that it's an
example where we are expecting user
input that we have absolutely no control
over we do not know what we're going to
be sent and the other thing is is that
we are probably going to be dealing with
users where we want to be able to give
some kind of meaning more meaningful
feedback if they give us invalid code so
we don't want to just throw and crash
which in many cases is actually quite a
valid error handling strategy here we
actually want to give some feedback on
what the error is why it's happened what
people can do about it and so this is
probably a kind of thing that you're
fairly familiar with when you're
starting a library so I've got a couple
of unit tests and I've picked some
examples out of a hat so I've said well
if I have a template which has no tags
in at all and a model that has no
replacement values I should be able to
render the template with the model and I
should get exactly the same string out
as I put in we could so far good I was
hoping that you know we'd get at least
this far if I have a template which has
a tag in and I give it a model which has
that tag in it named in the dictionary
and has a replacement value then it
should replace it so we we get the the
updated string
and we have an implementation so the
actual implementation we're starting
with is this one but I thought for those
of you haven't seen em shop before
there's a slightly more imperative
looking version below so this is kind of
in in classic TDD fashion this is kind
of the simplest thing I could think of
that could work kind off it doesn't work
for everything because we'll see later
so I thought you know if I just have one
tag what would I do
well probably I'd write a little reg X
that kind of looks for - opening curly
brackets optionally a space the name of
the tag optionally another space and
then two curly closing brackets and then
replace it with the replacement value
from the dictionary I've got more than
one of these so what am I going to do
I'm just going to create a new reg X
object for every key in my database and
do a replace on the text now hopefully
most of you will spot very quickly that
this has all kinds of different issues
so for example if your replacement text
has tags in those tags might get
triggered later by come later values
going through the dictionary its
enormous ly inefficient and you know a
few other little details like that but
we don't really care this will pass our
unit tests and in fact hopefully this is
up and running yeah hopefully you can
see that we have two two tests of have
passed so that's that's the example
we're going to work with and basically
what we're going to try and do is we're
going to try and build up to a fairly
robust piece of code that we have some
kind of well known good properties about
so so let's run out submit error
handling
so I'm glad most of you have seen some F
sharp before because I am using a few
sort of languages which don't a few
features that don't exist in in c-sharp
so I've got this idea that I want to try
and classify all of my errors because in
the problem where I was originally sort
of doing something similar to this I
needed to give localized error messages
so I didn't just want a string error
message about what had gone wrong I
actually wanted something that I could
sort of deal with programmatically later
so I've got this thing called a
discriminated Union it's kind of a an
enum on steroids
and so I can say okay well what's the
first level of error checking the first
area of level which error checking in a
dotnet library where I don't know
anything about the the inputs I'm
getting is just checking for nulls you
know null arguments and the normal
technique would be to throw a null
argument exception but here I'm wanting
to kind of give localised feedback on
what's going on so I'm not going to
throw an exception I'm going to capture
that error and and feed it back so at
the moment you know I can have a null
model or I can have null content my
original rendering library is now been
marked as private so it can't be called
directly and is wrapped with some error
handling so this is a pattern match
statement where I have the model and
some reason i've called the template
content and i have absolutely no idea
why my brain did that so i'll try and
correct that before i push the code up
to github for you guys and we just do a
little pattern match so i check whether
the model is null does this make sense
to people even if you haven't seen it
before so I've got little guard clause
there and this error and okay thing is
is something that's actually built into
the more recent versions of of F sharp
which is discriminated Union in its own
right where you can mark the result of a
function either being okay or being an
error so that looks good our tests have
changed a little bit
not a great deal so there's a couple of
things going on so one is I've given a
type alias for this result type that I'm
using so it's in c-sharp it just shows
up as a generic type with a success
result type and an error result type so
in c-sharp you'll either get back in an
okay of string or an error of a
rendering error and our tests have
updated slightly in that now in our
comparison what we're saying here is not
just that the result that comes back
should be the same string but that
actually it should be a result an okay
result of the same string you know it
should be a successful rendering of the
text and the result type has value
equality so this this equality will only
be true if the string inside the okay
type is the same in both cases because
the return type here is now a result and
again our replace text would be a result
of of okay as well yeah so again
hopefully this is all still fairly
familiar terra-tory let's actually bring
in our property based testing framework
so one of the nice things about property
based testing is you can kind of start
with simple things and then well simple
things to get properties for and then
you can move on to more complex things
so we do actually have an invariant
property for our code which is that we
don't want it to throw we don't ever
want it to throw we always want to give
meaningful feedback so we can write a
property that says something like this
at
okay so we're adding a few things here
so the property based testing library
that I'm using is called FS check I'll
have a link to it at the end it's fairly
established property based testing
librarian Nets been around for I think
about nine years now it's been around
for quite a while so I've obviously
added a reference to that and I'm using
X you know it's it's X unit plug in so I
can define properties easily so that's
in there there is also another newer
dotnet library called Hedgehog which
came out last year which I haven't had a
chance to play with yet but all of the
concepts we're covering today should
kind of apply equally equally to that
and having added FS check we can start
writing properties like this so they
look a bit like a test but there's a
couple of different things going on so
obviously we've got different attribute
where we're marking it as a property and
we're gonna call it does not throw
it's got inputs we're not specifying
what those inputs should be we're not
giving any example values we're just
saying yeah we want a string to use as a
template and we want a dictionary to use
as a model and then we're rendering the
text and we're returning true so
property ffs check it has a number of
things that can kind of consider as to
whether your property is passed or
failed the simplest and the most common
one is that your property returns a bool
and if the property holds true you
return true and if it doesn't you either
throw an exception or return false so
here we're fine because the only thing
we're checking is that it doesn't throw
exceptions so we can just return true
and if it throws an exception first then
hey we good now let's have a look any
problem with this is that our code no
longer passes our new test so let's have
a quick look what's going on here and so
are can you see that texture do you need
it a bit bigger people are the back
you're okay there's some requests for
bigger let's see if I can make it a bit
bigger it's gonna let me do it so we
don't need the details of the stacked
rest and things stacked race and things
okay that's interesting so that's that's
actually one of the errors that I was
planning to deal with later but this is
the joys of property based testing so so
what's actually happened here so it says
that the property has failed
it says the property is falsifiable so
it's sound is found a result where the
property has not returned true that it
took 12 tests to find it so what it's
done is it's generated 12 sets of input
data and for the first 11 of them the
property was true but now it's generated
a twelfth one and the property was not
true it then says that it's shrunk it
three times so this is one of the nice
things about FS checks if we look here
so the original property are found which
did not work is here so what it's saying
is it generated a template which was the
string xnp and then it's generated some
reason it's chosen to display the
dictionary as a sequence of key value
pairs I don't quite know why but hey
fair enough and so it generated a
sequence one with an empty string and a
couple of control characters I don't
know about you but I probably wouldn't
have come up with that as a unit test
anytime soon and the other one which I
suspect is the one that's causing a
problem is it generated one with a key
that has a asterisks in it and obviously
because all I'm doing is I'm taking my
key and I'm shoving it into a regex
expression and that's now generating in
invalid reg X so okay great and then I
get the stack trace and all the normal
things you would get because an
exception with thrown and and so on and
so forth yeah so fair enough
let's have a look at my implementation
it looks like I need valid keys
and so I can do something like so what
the way to one here I'm going to want to
a model I'm going to cheat and take that
okay so I'm going to pull all of the
keys out of the key value pairs and I'm
going to say that how do we want to make
keys valid I'm going to say a couple of
things about it I'm going to say that
well contact today so I'm going to say
that my identifier has to start with a
letter I'm pretty gonna have to specify
that that's a string and
[Music]
so so basically why I'm just gonna go
through here isn't gonna get all of the
keys I'm going to check that the first
character is definitely a letter and I'm
going to check that all of the let all
of the characters are either letters or
digits that kind of make sense so I'm
double checking the first character I
don't really care so I can go
was I call it invalid key
okay so hopefully we should get a new
set of tests at this point assuming I've
actually written that correctly oh yeah
sorry so it's now just told me that I've
tried to index the first letter of an
empty string which it doesn't like so
let's have a check before that to say
[Music]
oh yeah so so our key actually needs to
have some some stuff in it
okay that passed that's slightly
unexpected must emit but let's actually
have a look at the kind of things that
that's doing so if we go back to our
property for a moment we can actually
have a look at what's going on
oh I'm I'm doing that wrong out on time
okay so let's have a look it's not
terribly useful because it's and not
showing us a very nice representation of
the dictionaries but you can kind of
imagine what's going on with the
dictionaries because what are we doing
is it will be generating the same kind
of strings that's generating for the
keys so we're getting a whole load of
strings here so some of them are empty
some of them are quite short some of
them are starting to have weird
characters in what you won't see in this
display is that it will start generating
control characters and things and some
of them will be null so this is kind of
what FS check does for you and let's
let's get back onto a prepared bits
yes that's fine
no that hasn't done what I wanted
let's give up something
so this is a slightly extended version
of coats this is one of the things about
property testing you need to watch out
for if you say add it to your CI or
something is that depending what
properties in what values it happens to
generate by default it runs a hundred
examples you might end up getting
different things put into your different
results from your tests so when I was
preparing this talk at different points
when I was running the code I actually
got different examples of things that it
found that it didn't find the first time
so for example I found out that you know
if it gave a null replacement value in
the dictionary than that cause to regex
to fail and it's sort of a bunch of
other things like that
so one thing to be aware of with
property based testing is that it does
have the the slightly annoying
occasional property of you will write
some code you'll get the property based
test to pass you checked into your CI
and then after a while you will suddenly
get a random error that you weren't
expecting fortunately it always tells
you what the input was that created that
error so you can go back and add a sort
of individual unit case as a regression
oh sorry an individual unit test as a
regression test for that kind of
particularly unusual input cool okay
that's not what I wanted I wanted my
tests again
this is great and this is actually quite
kind of a useful property to be able to
write for code it's just kind of being
able to say okay give me whatever inputs
you like I should do something kind of
meaningful with it and this is also the
kind of property that's quite easy to
write if you have the kind of invariance
we were talking about earlier yeah you
can kind of see how you could write a
property like this saying I'll sort my
list backwards and forwards and all
those kind of things but we don't always
you know we can't really say very much
about what results should be if we're
just saying give us any string at all
because if that input template is null
well hey we can't you know it's an error
but if it's something meaningful we
would expect it to return okay and we're
just told FS check to generate any
string at all it's it's kind of hard to
know what we should be what we should be
checking here so okay so the first thing
that might spring to mind is so if FS
check is is generating inputs based on
the types how about if we create a type
who's whose know has a constructor that
makes sure that we know something about
the input so let's let's give that a go
[Music]
so hopefully in here we should now have
our tagless string class so our next
property we're gonna write is we're
going to go okay
so testing actually that we're getting
the correct results is quite hard quite
new to property based testing so maybe
for the moment we all have specific
examples for actual genuine templates
with real models where we want to do
replacements we'll kind of put some
examples in for that but surely at least
we can check that property that if the
input has no tags in it should be
unchanged you know that's that's that's
relatively straightforward so how can we
do that
well all we need is a string that never
has a pair of opening a double pair of
opening braces because if it doesn't
have a double pair of opening braces
there's no tax so cool we're programmers
we could we can do we can do logic and
we need a type because we're going to
kind of indicate two FS check that this
is what we want so let's create a class
class is just gonna have a single
property on it which we're just gonna
call value which is the stream that gets
generated it takes any any input string
and then what it does is it just sits
there in a little loop for as long as
the string contains a pair of opening
braces it loops back round and replaces
the pair with a single one again until
there's no pairs left and it also does
something else which may not immediately
spring to mind but your property based
testing will tell you quite quickly if
you forget about it
which is that later on we're going to be
kind of gluing some of these strings
together to try and generate whole
template inputs so if one of them ends
with an opening brace and one of them
begins with an opening brace and they
end up next to each other we actually
end up with an opening of a tag so we're
just going to say that if if we ever
generate something that ends with a
curly bracket we're going to stick an
eye on the end just you know something
no you would never write code like this
in production this this is this is
purely tech code to generates the kind
of input that we want and and that's
part of the benefit here because this
code will never have the same logic as
the code you're testing so one of the
things we're doing here is that you know
the logic that you need to generate a
string that has no tags in is totally
independent of the logic you need to
parse your template so you're never
going to sort of end up with duplicating
your production code in your test
generators unless you do something
seriously wrong at some point yeah but
all we're doing here is we want to put
some kind of constraint on the input
which means that we now know mean now
know something meaningful about the
output and the constraint we've put is
there's no tags and the result of that
is that we know that we should get
something that there doesn't change when
we feed it through our renderer and the
other thing which is nice to do is to
override to string to give something
nice because when our property fails
what FS check will do is it will tell
you which of your tagless strings has
caused the property to fail and
obviously if you don't have that you
just get the class name which is not
particularly helpful so I'll tack with
string and this is where we start to get
into slightly more of the magic so what
we have here is we have a new property
and the property is still quite simple
so we get our tag list string as a
template we extract the value give it to
our rendering function and we say that
the result that comes back should be
okay rather than error because that's
one of the things we can check and if
it's okay
the value
stored in that okay result should be the
same as the value that we put in and if
not we're going to throw an exception
that gives a string representation of
our our error to do is that lets get
that running again
so that's great but we also have this
piece of magic here let me just check
see if that runs yeah it's well it turns
out we've got two problems so one is
we've got this piece of magic here which
we'll explain in a moment and the other
is that it turns out as often happens in
property based testing that things are
not quite as simple as they first appear
because it turns out that actually our
property that we thought we had of if we
give it a string that has no tags in it
should always work and it should always
come back unchanged isn't actually true
because we also have some constraints on
what we consider a valid model so if for
example like here we generate a model
that has an invalid key we still don't
get an okay result out because although
our template is fine our keys in our
model are not
so here we have an empty string so an
invalid key is being supplied so okay so
we've got a couple of things to sort out
so let's have a look at the magic first
so we've got this thing here we're now
kind of configuring our property and
we're saying this thing here that we
want to feed a new arbitrary in so I'm
not quite sure about the naming here but
in in FS checks speech an arbitrary is a
thing that knows how to create an
arbitrary value of a type and it uses
reflection to do that so we have a
generator class that will have members
that know how to generate types so let's
have a look at our generator
if my machine doesn't crash that would
be fun
okay that's them now it's it's not it's
not liking that just reload that
we'll make you larger again in a moment
yeah
Oh Oh what happened there let's have a
look at our generator so what we've got
is we've got this a class it's got a
static member on it which is of a
generic type an arbitrary of tagless
string and this is how we actually tell
FS check how to generate tagless strings
because tagless strings is something it
has no internal concept of you know it
has generators for many of the base
class values so it can generate dates
and it can generate strings and it can
generate dictionaries and lists and and
those kind of things but this is this is
a class that we've created it's got no
real way of knowing how we want to
create it now for this one we can
actually do something fairly
straightforward so what we can do is we
can say actually we we've kind of added
some constraints to this but basically
it's just a string so what we can do is
we can tell efforts check how to convert
back and forth from something it knows
how to generate already so we're going
to create a new arbitrary based on an
unknown string arbitrary so I'm saying
hey I don't want null strings and this
none null generic type is actually built
into FS check and basically all it does
is you can wrap any other type and say
use your default generator but don't
give me any null ones of that thing and
I can croute I can give a little lambda
functions to convert in either direction
so I can say if you give me a string
which is not null sort of wrapped in
this none know thing then I can just
call my constructor that does has all of
the logic I need to remove the tags and
if I want to go the other way I already
know that my string is not null because
I'm generating this from a not null
string and so I can go okay give it I
will convert it back by giving a new non
null the reason you want about to
convert in both directions as you saw
before FS check had this thing where it
kind of shrunk the input so it found a
value that didn't work and then it made
it smaller until it found the minimal
value that didn't work and so Albert
Rees are actually built up of two things
in FS check they're built up of a
general
waiter that knows how to just generate
one of these values and a shrinker that
knows how to reduce the size of the
value now the shrinker is optional so
for some of there are other examples we
won't be providing shrinkers but if they
are quite nice because it means that
when you get the failing test you always
kind of get the minimal version of it so
the default string shrinker not entirely
surprisingly basically just tries to
knock characters out of the string until
it finds a version that passes and then
it gives you the kind of the last
version that didn't and I think it
actually tries to increment back down
through the characters as well so you'll
quite often get a minimal error of just
the string a because what it will do is
it will start up for the longest string
it will not let us out until there's
only one letter left and then it will
start incrementing back down through the
ASCII codes until it gets back to a and
then it will say a lower class a
lowercase a doesn't pass your test and
so you guys that's that's kind of the
the first step of being able to tell FS
check about your domain you can create
types that represent constraints on your
domain and then you can tell FS check
how to generate them and we kind of
thought we were done
except yeah we've added these checks
that test that all of our input is valid
and our model isn't valid so that's
that's slightly frustrating what can we
do there well we could do something like
we could take this out and just have a
sort of an empty dictionary but that's
not really what we want to test because
there are going to be cases where people
are going to send through models with
data in and templates that have no tags
is kind of a valid use case so let's
have a think about how we can how we can
generate these
No
it already
sorry I've forgotten that modifying the
files would would cause issues with that
let's have a look in there we were point
actually okay so this is what your
generator start looking like so we're
going to have an arbitrary of I
dictionary so so here we're doing
something slightly different so here
we've actually defined our own class and
we're using the class as kind of a flag
to F s check of sometimes we'll want to
generate tankless strings and sometimes
we won't the other thing you can do and
I'm kind of showing this here for ya to
show that it can be done you might want
to actually wrap this if you were doing
these tests for real is you can also
override the default generators of
existing types so here for example I can
say okay the ideation areas that I want
you to generate I always want you to
generate valid input models anywhere
that I use this configuration you know
so anything that asks for an Ida canary
give it and give it a valid one so I'm
going to override the default generator
so what does it end up looking like well
I kind of I know all of the the first
characters that are valid because I've
said the first character has to be a
letter I know that the other characters
can be letters or numbers
that's just a nasty little function for
sticking a single character and then an
array of other characters together into
a string and you end up writing code
like this now this is where things start
to get a little bit brain hurty and and
this is probably the main concept that i
want to go with for today so if you
start to lose the plot totally do feel
free to stick your hand up and tell me
but as you can see what we're actually
doing is we're using a link expression
to generate our values and kind of the
way to think about this is that in say a
link to SQL expression what you're doing
is you're saying is from the context of
the database I'm connected to get me a
value that matches these criteria
what we're doing here is we're saying
from the context of all possible things
this generator could potentially
generate get me one of them does that
kind of make sense so this generator
here so gender elements is a generator
that's built into FS check and you can
give it an array and it will generate at
random one of the elements of the array
so what I'm saying here is I have this
array of characters that are valid first
characters for my key from that space of
potential characters give me one of them
that's going to be my first character
and I can stick generators together so
for the rest of the characters I want I
want a bunch of characters I don't care
how many cuz I've got at least one
character now so I've got a valid
identifier but I want to glue
potentially some number of other
characters onto the end to give me a
variety of different identifiers so I'm
going to say okay I've got this array
that has all of the legal characters for
an identifier from that array pick me
one of them and do that multiple times
to generate a random array of characters
this current is this still kind of
making sense to people
some people are nodding and then give me
one of those arrays so I'm saying from
the so we've got this kind of generator
that can generate any kind any length of
array and the elements in that array
will be elements from my valid input
keys and I can also make use of FS
checks of default generators so I can
say and I need a valid replacement value
so from the the the generator of none
null strings that's built in I don't
know how that works and I don't care
give me a string that isn't null and
call it replaced
and then in my select clause I can do
what I need to with these this is my
merge function that just takes a
character an array of characters glues
them together it turns them into a
string so that becomes my key and my
null string I just extract it from that
none null wrapper to get the whatever
the string is so now I have a generator
of key value pairs that have valid
values in but I don't want key value
pairs I want an ID Ixion's
so what I can say is I can say okay
generate me a none empty list again this
is built into FS check generate me a
none empty list of key value pairs and
then in my Select cause here we do
something a little bit nasty because we
want our keys
we need our keys to be unique so what we
do is if we've generated duplicate keys
we just take the first value that was
generated and throw the rest away and
then we build a dictionary of whatever's
left and then the last thing we need to
do is now we have a generator of I
dictionaries as I said before in FS
check an arbitrary is a combination of a
generator and a shrinker but I'm just
going to use this dot Fromm method that
basically says I don't know how to
shrink this yeah I can generate these
but I don't know how to shrink them so
just you know don't try basically
so this I think is you know where we
really start to see the full power of FS
check because what you can do is you can
start abstracting things you know about
your domain out into these generators
and then you can keep your properties
very simple so our property hasn't
changed you know if we are given a
tankless string and a valid model then
our string shouldn't change so you know
our property is still very simple
someone coming into the code base can
come along they can have a look and for
someone who even someone who hasn't used
property based testing this for the
reader it kind of looks almost the same
as when you do a what would be in an X
unit a theory where you then have a list
of example values to feed in it's just
that we don't have the list of example
values we're just saying it's always
true it always happens so this is lovely
and in the last 10 minutes I'm going to
see if I can cover the next bit and you
can get a long way using FS check in
c-sharp and as you can see the code code
actually looks relatively nice there is
one issue with using FS check from C
sharp which the F sharp an
implementation sorry it is the F sharp
implementation the F sharp language
allows you to get round slightly which
is there you have linked expressions in
c-sharp but what you cannot do in a
linked expression is you cannot have a
conditional so you cannot within a
single linked expression say something
like generate me the first character and
if it's lowercase do this and if it's
uppercase do something different that
starts getting really nasty and you if
you try and actually write something
which does that you'll see that your
your code immediately kind of explodes
but fortunately F sharp allows us to
work around this so I'm going to get
quickly across to the F sharp version of
this code to see if we can add something
a bit more so at the moment this is
basically exactly the same as the C
sharp version so I've got a few
type aliases just to make the the code a
bit shorter hopefully they're fairly
self-explanatory we have our type our
tagless string class still yep yeah yep
yeah so the question here is if you if
you if you if you actually change a
property of your code and production you
know something that was a property in
the past now no longer is can that cause
issues with the generators being hard to
understand the answer is yes to an
extent but part of the answer is also
that if your property has changed as in
if a fundamental property of your code
has changed then probably that generator
is no longer what you want anyway so I
mean this is something I actually say
about unit testing in general not just
property based testing that I sometimes
have had conversations with people
saying oh you know we're refactoring
this piece of code now how bunch of our
tests don't pass anymore we've got loads
of work to do and one of the first
questions to always ask is does that
test even matter anymore and quite often
the answer is well no because we're not
doing the same thing anymore so we don't
need the same same test for it and yeah
I mean it's like any other code if if no
one know if no one understands it then
you have an unmaintainable piece of code
the advantage is it's test so you can
always throw it away you know you can
always replace it with a bunch of
examples and you're good so which is
nice for doing things like bringing in
new languages like F sharp as well you
know it's like you can write the
properties more expressively an F sharp
for production code people have valid
concerns about hey no one knows F sharp
yet we don't want production code we
can't maintain for something like this
it's relatively easy to argue hey isn't
this a great way to learn and if I ever
leave and no one else has bothered to
pick it up well you've got some code you
can delete next time it breaks you know
it's not kind of a big big issue because
at the end of the day most of the value
in tests is actually during the creation
process I mean it's nice to have
regression tests as well but the
majority of the benefit is actually
upfront
it's whilst you're writing the code does
that
yeah yes we saw got our tackler string
here I actually wrapped the valid key in
a in a type as well but it's very
similar kind of thing
there's our converters back and forth
between different bits so our tackler
string generator that's kind of the
equivalent of the the valid key
generator bit in F sharp so this is kind
of what I wanted to show you is that
this is what the syntax starts looking
like an F sharp so so f sharp has this
thing that's where you would kind of do
from in a link expression you use this
let bang operator I that's kind of a
choice that was made and let bang we'll
do different things depending on this
name here outside the curly brackets so
if that said async let bang would expect
the thing on the right here to be an
async and opener would be the result
that was awaited for the async if here I
have the gen computational expression
that's what these these bits are called
then let bang expects a generator on the
right and the thing on the left is the
thing that was generated still making
sense so far and the only thing to be
aware of here is that what you're kind
of doing here with these gen
computational expressions is the thing
you return here is not a single value
you're actually returning a generator so
what you're building in this block here
is you're building the logic to generate
something you're not actually generating
at a particular value you're building up
the recipe for for generating things and
then different testing framework but
hopefully this looks very similar so we
have in fact we don't even need any
any config on that one we just want to
generate any values at all and you can
also do things in FS check like you can
actually label your the different cases
in your in your properties so as well as
telling you the the error that failed it
will give you the the label that you've
assigned there when it fails so let's
see if in six minutes we can have a
quick look how would go about generating
something that actually tries to prove
kind of the correctness of our function
rather than just kind of a simple
property about it like you know it
doesn't throw or something like that so
let's
yeah you want me to reset that
okay so let's have a look here this is
what you were asking before about you
know isn't that code read I'll glean
something you never want to use in
production yes yes it is don't write
code like that in production so what
what we kind of want to do here is that
we know that if we just generate a model
and a template at random even if they're
valid ones what do we expect the output
to be and if we just say two FS check
okay generate me a model generate me a
template they're both valid give them to
me and my property if we then try to
write that property to say is the result
correct what would actually end up doing
is we'd end up rewriting our production
code because we'd have to do exactly the
same thing we'd have to parse the input
we'd have to swap in all the values and
then we'd have to go do we get the same
result now that that kind of can be
valid one thing I've actually done which
is quite fun is you can actually get two
teams and we actually did this working
in different programming languages and
we just wrote two implementations of the
code and property based test them
against each other which was kind of fun
as an exercise but not an especially
efficient use of time in actually
writing real code so what we do is we
kind of reverse that logic and go okay
how about if we think about this the
other way around how about if if we get
FS checked not just to tell us the
inputs but also to tell us the expected
output because in our generator we know
what data we're generating so we can use
those property we can use those values
without having to do any parsing or
anything like that we already have those
because we're the ones generating them
so let's kind of have a think about how
we might be able to do this so let's
let's say that our property is going to
take this input of of I've got a
template situation or a template context
here and it's got the two input fields
but it also has the expected output
I don't want generates
no sorry so if we have a look to our
property our property stays very simple
because we want to render the text of
the model in the template and then we
expect the rendered text to equal the
expected text that we were given so
that's great but how do we go about
doing that and this is where the code
starts to become really really ugly if
you try and write it as a link
expression and so mark Seaman did a
whole talk about this yesterday which
slightly sir really is called dependency
injection revisited I think but it's
actually about how writing this type of
code in C sharp is is a bad idea and you
should actually use the right tool for
the job okay so let's have a look so we
want some some input data so we want to
generate some key value pairs we have
already overridden this generator to
only so if you remember we over rid the
default generator for the model so we
can just say go off and generate us one
using this object command and that will
that will use our overriding it would
generate us valid a valid model and then
we say okay so what what can each piece
of the template look like well it can
either look like a string that has no
tags in in which case the output should
be the same as the input or it might be
a tag in which case the input should be
like curly brackets and the tag name and
the output should be the replacement
value so for a tag list section we're
good we kind of have a generator for
this so what we're going to do is we're
going to have a generator that returns a
tuple of input and output for each type
of section so for a tag list section we
generate the tag list string we return
the values and for a tagged section we
return a tag and the replacement
and now I can say generate me a list of
either one or the other then I can build
up a string of the expected inputs and a
string of the expected outputs and then
I can return a model that has my data in
and basically this is the thing I wants
to get to and that's good because it's
almost exactly 20 past this idea that we
can yes the generators become complex
yes they end up with a lot of logic in
them but it is logic which you are it is
enforced upon you as the person writing
the tests that this logic is independent
of your actual production logic and it
can give you really nice confidence of
things that you never would have thought
of in your tests and one of the things I
do in the other talk which I will put up
on the screen now is I actually go
through a bunch of the kinds of errors
that you get that you weren't expecting
how frustrating that can be on one hand
and kind of how much of a game it can
compare on the other because rather than
property rather than unit tests where
you keep on having to write the next one
for your TDD with property based
testings you just get the next error you
just write your one property and believe
me it will take a while to to get all
the the errors to go away so just quick
run through FS check is there that's my
blog if you search for FS check on there
you'll find a number of examples
including this talk with more examples
with less details from a few years ago
and just a quick plug for my employer
who do not used on it but do use
property based testing who are a company
called no red ink and I think that's
about it I would only have time for
questions I'm afraid but come and find
me afterwards if you're interested thank
you very much
[Applause]
like